if you like computer games you're at
risk Trojans can steal your game items
but how does it work a player of csgo
Dota 2 Team Fortress 2 Warframe and
other games receive a message in game
chat offering to swap inventory for a
bargain the message contains a link that
downloads a Trojan onto the victim's
computer sometimes a steam user is
offered to join a multiplayer game and
after a successful match is offered to
download a trojanized voice
communication software this Trojan
injects itself in the process of steam
application and searches for inventory
by keywords such as rare mythical
Immortal legendary and similar the
stolen inventory is transferred by the
attackers to their accounts to be sold
for real money game Trojans often run a
key logger on the computer that records
the keys pressed and transmits them to
the attackers in this way hackers can
find out the login and password to a
steam account vermers regularly create
new versions of Trojans and sell or rent
them to hackers